لم يكن محمد يبالي باسعار الوقود سابقا
لكن التقلبات التي يشهدها الاقتصاد
الباكستاني منذ اشهر جراء قيام الحكومه
برفع اسعار المشتقات النفطيه واستمرار
تذبذب اسعار العمله امام الدولار وفرض
ضرائب جديده دفعته لاعاده ترتيب اولوياته
كل صباح تقريبا نجد اسعار جديده ومرتفعه
وليس من السهل بناء على ذلك ان ارتب
مصاريفي بين احتياجات البيت وفاتوره
الكهرباء وتكلفه تعليم الابناء وبين
متطلبات العمل هذا صعب للغايه
تعاني باكستان ازمه اقتصاديه هي الاسوا
منذ عقود فقد ارتفع معدل التضخم الى اعلى
مستوى له في نصف قرن يصبح البلد هو السابع
عشر في العالم من حيث الغلاء
العمله المحليه هي الاخرى فقدت نحو ربع
قيمتها امام الدولار منذ بدايه العام
الجاري وسجلت احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي
مؤشرات حرجه لا تغطي الواردات الخارجيه
لاكثر من شهر واحد
بواقع باكستان حيث يجب ضبط السياسات
الماليه ورفع سعر الفائده وتعويم العمله
وفرض مزيد من الضرائب وايقاف الدعم
تكافح باكستان منذ اشهر العوده الى اتفاق
سابق مع صندوق النقد الدولي للحصول على
دفعه بمليار دولار من اصل قروض تبلغ
قيمتها الاجماليه سته مليارات ونصف مليار
دولار امريكي اوقفها الصندوق بسبب رفض
حكومه عمران خان السابقه رفع اسعار
الفائده وسحب دعم الكهرباء والمشتقات
النفطيه والغاز وتحرير سعر صرف العمله
ورفع القيود الحكوميه على الاستيراد وفرض
مزيد من الضرائب
حكومه شهباز شريف الحاليه وان كانت تصف
تلك الشروط بالقاسيه الا انها وافقت على
تلبيتها تتضمن الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
الحكومه حتى الان رفع سعر الفائده من 17%
الى 20% وزياده اسعار الوقود والطاقه
والغاء الدعم عنها واعتماد سعي صرف قائم
على السوق وفرض ضرائب جديده وتقليص
النفقات الحكوميه
تنظر الحكومه الباكستانيه لحل الازمه
بعيني واحده صوب مطالب صندوق النقد الدولي
التي تصفها بالقاسيه واخرى نحو شارع تخشى
رده فعله لاسيما مع استمرار ارتفاع
الاسعار سمير النمري الجزيره اسلام اباد